foreign
out in Dallas Texas what's up Ann
hi John thank you so much for taking my
call thank you are you kidding thank you
for calling in fact it means the world
to me and thank you so much thank you I
listen to you all the time and the more
I listen to you this is why I asked you
on on Facebook
um and I'm so thankful that you're
taking my call
um the more I listen to you the more
I've learned so much from you
um let me just I'm 63 years old okay
I've been a homemaker for many many
years
I've been through abuse in my marriage
okay so it's my second marriage I've
been married before for five years in my
teens
um so with that background I didn't want
to go through another divorce
so I married my husband I thought he was
wonderful
and I put up with abuse I had three more
children I have four I have three more
children
I stayed at home raising them
and now I feel all my kids are grown and
gone I have grandchildren now
and it just hit me
um
I feel
if I could have redo's I would redo I
feel the more I'm hearing you and the
more I'm reading
and reading God's word the more I know
that we shouldn't have put up with abuse
we can't control others like I always
hear you say you can't control anyone
but yourself and I've been trying to
change my husband to have more value for
me and
um I've allowed abuse and no connection
and lies
and I know I've done that and I have
regrets
how do I do how do I
get I have your book in front of me I
just got it in the mail
how do I own my past and change my
future wow because
and that's so much
um
it's a lot well 34 years of marriage
are y'all are y'all still married
okay we
we still share a home
pardon me in the same home we share a
home okay but it's he knows only because
we were building a home
after we started building a home he
broke my fingers
I would have left them right then and
there my son was going to be married the
next day we were putting on a dinner in
two hours
so I didn't know what to do
so after the wedding I had my hand was
in a cast and everything
how did you break your fingers
he grabbed him he got angry grabbed him
and crunched them what a scumbag dude I
called I caught him in a lie it was with
another woman
flirting with another
hornered because I said just tell the
truth because he would lie to me all the
time and he left us he left the kids and
I in their teen years for four years I
was foolish enough to get back with him
hey hold on one second hold on a second
hold on a second okay
somebody somewhere along the way Anne
told you that there's something wrong
with you
and somebody along the way told you that
you're dumb
and somebody along the way told you
like the difference like dumb is you
don't have the right information in your
head
and somebody else told you you're an
idiot
you're a sucker
and I don't think that at all
and those people who told you that
okay
have informed over time the story that
you have begun to tell yourself
and so before we go any further
you're not dumb and you're not an idiot
you survived
you're we're abused did you stay yes you
did
you stayed alive
you stayed fed you stayed in a warm
place
and you're not dumb and you're not less
than and you didn't fail okay
okay
I I the
we could probably go back to you or
seven and just spend several hours
together I'd love to hear your story I
can tell you in just a few minutes of
talking to you that you were
incredibly compassionate and kind and
thoughtful
and that you've been running
interference on a really
bad person for a long time is that fair
does it hey doesn't matter what they
think
behind closed doors in people's homes is
almost always different
right and when that happens you end up
looking and feeling crazy because people
come tell you over the last 30 years
what a great guy and oh my gosh like
you're so lucky
and there's part of you that thinks uh
it's probably me
and then he breaks your hand in a
grown-up temper tantrum and somehow you
work that into the stories converge in
your mind in land
well it's I'm just gonna get through
this and then I'm gonna get through that
and then I just need to suck it up and
buckle up here and I'm just gonna make
sure you see what I'm saying and all of
a sudden you land right back in the same
place
I did my son's wedding was the next date
and I thought what are they gonna do
yeah
what would have been awesome and this is
this is awesome as an outsider right not
this would have been terrible for your
family would have been awesome
if Dad had missed the funeral because
his butt was in jail
right right and now we're breaking the
bones of an extraordinary 60 year old
woman that would have been awesome
and that would have been absent from all
photos all pictures all memories that
had been fantastic didn't happen that
way that's cool get that
ultimately
here we are
and so my question for you is
what do you want to do
because you've done I mean you've owned
the past
probably too much
you have
taken all those bricks in your backpack
over the last several years I'm guessing
and you have looked at them and examined
them
and you've come to say whoa whoa whoa
whoa I'm worth more than this I always
have been and so what I got married when
I was a child and then it didn't work
out that doesn't mean I was destined or
required to have a life of abuse and
infidelity and anger and rage and
protecting my kid like I'm worth more
than this the challenge is you've taken
the bricks out of your backpack but
you're still holding them all
and you haven't set them down
well I don't want my kids I didn't want
to raise my kids without a father I
would hear I was raised on Dr Dobson
yeah and he said you don't it's worse to
to raise them without a father
so I kept hanging on to back because I
listened to Dr Dobson all the time so
I'm not going to speak of Dr Dobson okay
I don't know enough about it and that
was before what I will tell you is
anybody who tells you it's better to
stay in an abusive relationship where
mom is being beat up cheated on yelled
at excluded
that's better than not having a man in
the house is should not have a
microphone
they're insane
okay
so how do I go from here yeah that okay
so that's important so let's we'll
toggle
to
here's like I think regret is important
but it's got a really short shelf life
to it it's like Wasabi right eating it
like if you go get sushi and eat wasabi
it burns like fire real for a second and
then all of a sudden it's just gone
right that's regret you look back and go
man I wish I could have done that over
and then really quick you come to right
now
because you can't you can't most people
get stuck in the I wish I should have
just I should have just done it all
differently and here here I am
shouldn't have gained this much weight
over the last 10 years and I'm 100
pounds overweight just is what it is I'm
just gonna whatever
and then we have you have to ask
yourself the terrifying scary Brave next
question which is what do I want next
I want free yeah
I want free
so here's my here's my here's my
response to that number one
and hear me say this directly as I can
you deserve to be free and I never ever
tell somebody
to get divorced
you need to get away from a man who's
breaking your bones and cheating on you
today
okay and here's the other thing I know
too
okay I've read the data for too long
and women who leave abusive
relationships end up on the street
because they got no place to go
so my question is where would you go do
you have a family a child that you could
move in with do you have and I'm not
talking about for two weeks I'm talking
about for six months do you have money
saved that you could or have access to
okay I have money you could go to an
apartment and stay right do you have a
place to go you have your four walls is
the way we say it here is you have food
Transportation clothing and home like
with your you know your home and your
utilities things like that
yes if there's about there we were
building a house in the in
the Builder didn't finish it and so we
were in the lawsuit we we sued him which
we never sued anybody but anyway we're
done well we're trying to get just cut
our ties and lose it but now we so we
have about it'll be about eight hundred
thousand is what what we will have after
the house is sold
so
um what you're going to need to do is
get an attorney
okay to walk alongside you otherwise
that money goes in his pocket and you
end up destitute and it happens too
often
okay so you get an attorney that will
walk alongside you
okay and you get a couple of girlfriends
that will walk alongside you that you
can tell everything to and that you
trust and that you can say
here's what's been going on in my home
have you ever done that
have I have okay and and um have you
gotten burned
I did
um this one person I trusted and I would
trust her with anything
they did something her and her family
being a Christian that I didn't agree
with that it was against God's word okay
um so you know I heard you and Dave on
the show the other just the other day
saying you go you got to make friends
you got to make friends she was my best
friend for 37 years yeah and I had to
let it go yeah just and we're not that
close anymore because I called her out
on it okay so what whatever whatever
value violation happened it happened
okay your next hard work is to get new
friends
okay it's just got to be a part of a
thing and it might be for a season
you're going to pay a therapist to go
sit with in fact I would a thousand
percent recommend the two places you
need to spend money is you need an
attorney and you need to get a counselor
okay okay
and
expect the freedom to come at a price
both a true like a real price and this
will be scary because this is what you
have known for so long
and so hear me say this I want these
words to Rattle around in your soul let
them park there
you're worth a home
you're worth being loved
there's nobody has any business putting
their hands on you ever ever known as
any business telling you that you're
anything other than wonderful
ever you're worth somebody not cheating
on you
I wonder where somebody's been and what
diseases you're getting in your own
house
all of that sounds like before you even
called you're ready
I'm ready I'm ready I
hope you for your I felt stuck because
of this house situation and I'm not
stuck anymore I don't I'll yeah I'm not
stuck anymore if you reach out to one of
your kids would they take you in for a
season
um yes but I don't want to do that so I
do have money I can't I know I know hold
on hold on it might be a great great
gift to your kids
oh okay and when this happens they've
seen this for years right they've
watched this
have they talked to you about it before
my daughter I have two boys and one girl
okay and my daughter says Mom I'm really
angry why you never left him years ago
okay
my two boys
oh Mom you know Dad oh mom so they make
excuses for their dad it's bull crap
dude that's how that crap rolls downhill
and they're gonna do it to their kids
and on and on and on and on right it's
Gotta stop has to stop so I'd call your
daughter and by the way when she says
stuff like that that's her working on
her pain okay
um and that's that's take that with a
grain of salt okay
okay
um
she's working through her stuff too I'd
call her and say today's the day it's
time can I come stay with you for a few
weeks will you help me find an apartment
will you help me set up my bills and the
internet and the electricity and those
kind of things will you help me get my
own cell phone plan we help me get car
insurance all those little knick-knacky
things that may have just happened you
may have been doing this for years but
it's all the knickknack stuff it's like
oh I don't even know where my uh I can
do it I I handled everything so awesome
I did I I got all the stuff okay call
your daughter and walk walk her through
this too if she's safe okay and if she
offers mom I want you to come stay with
us
give her that gift
and at the same time you'll be giving
yourself the gift too if she says well
where are you gonna go you got an
apartment then that might be her saying
man maybe not mine maybe not my house
and you can say great
I'm Ann and I'm rich hey she just had a
baby but it might be awesome if you were
there to hold that baby too
okay okay because that would be lovely
let's see for me yeah that would be
wonderful well and here's the thing I'm
trying to trick you it would be a gift
for her but it would be therapeutic and
healing for you
because you're gonna go to your own
apartment and you're gonna get really
really lonely
and I think it's been a long time since
I looked at it
is it Kelly me is it seven times people
go back to an abusive relationship
before they leave
before they leave finally
yourself
because they go away and they get lonely
and they get scared and they get quiet
and then they go back and then they go
back then they go back
out of loneliness so I want you to have
people in your life well sometimes they
go down because they're just hungry they
don't have money right I mean these are
like basic things it's easy to say yeah
you should just march on out of there
but for millions and millions of women
the question is okay where where do I
eat and so have money good good good
good you probably want to put in your
own account all here's to do all that
stuff your attorney's gonna walk you
through okay okay and your counselor
walk you through so I'll stop giving you
tips I'm just throwing stuff at you now
hear me say you're worth more than this
nonsense
thank you okay you're right it happened
young it did happen young it did and
you've carried the story with you for a
long long time and it's time to set that
story down and here's the deal you spent
a ton of energy 30 plus years of energy
trying to go back and edit a story that
has already happened
I'm trying to edit that story and spend
all of the rest of your precious thought
and Brilliance and grit and
determination
and write something new what comes next
okay okay
okay will you do that you're coming to
Dallas yes yes John and you're going to
come to Dallas I'm going to go see you
all I'll be in I'll be in Dallas in the
fall and um yes I look forward to seeing
you
is that cool
that's great and then as far as a job
like okay
okay I do have money but do I get a job
you will need a job yes
um for multiple reasons that's not
priority number one
if you've I've talked to people who I've
got to get a job today because I'm I
don't have any like I'll have no money
you're not in that situation it will you
will have to sit down with a financial
advisor at some point and walk through
okay what's the rest of my life look
like
and
um that's fine that's that's part of it
that's cool
okay you'll figure that part out as you
go
um right now it's being safe and you're
not safe you're stuck
you've got somebody you you've got a a
bear a rhinoceros sleeping in the bed
next to you
who just gets mad and breaks your bones
God that rages me out so much
and I'm so grateful for you
I must say Something's Gonna get me in
trouble I'm just gonna go to break and
we love you keep us in touch and let us
know how we're doing